welcome to fox square here in midtown
Manhattan home of America's election
headquarters on the eve of the historic
midterm elections we have a jam-packed
hour ahead but first Fox News Alert in
the final hours before voters head to
the polls president Trump's hitting the
campaign trail harder than ever as he
tries at simp key toss-up races with a
flurry of rallies in three states hours
ago in Cleveland the president fired up
the crowd by drilling down on what's at
stake for our country and achieved is at
stake or an election day it is if the
Radical Democrats take power they will
take a wrecking ball to our economy a
vote for Republicans as they vote to
continue our extraordinary prosperity
our extraordinary journey together a
vote for Democrats is a vote to bring
this economic boom crashing to a sudden
halt the Democrat agenda is a socialist
nightmare for our contract meanwhile
Democratic big guns are coming out to
try to stop Trump Barack Obama going
after the president and the GOP America
is at a crossroads the health care of
millions is on the ballot a fair shape
for work and Families is on the ballot
perhaps most importantly the character
of our country and former New York City
Mayor Michael Bloomberg dishing out
millions on a new campaign ad backing
Democratic candidates we expect to be
called to a higher purpose we expect to
work together I don't hear that call
coming from Washington these days do you
in fact I hear the opposite shouting and
hysterics instead of calm reasoning
pointed fingers instead of open hands
division instead of unity we must send a
signal to Republicans in Washington that
they have failed to lead failed to find
solutions and fail to bring us together
that's why I'm voting Democratic okay
Martha welcome to the five all right so
the the closing message for the
Democrats seems to be health care and
Trump is divisive and racist and the
Republican closing message seems to be
immigration the economy and the
Democrats are unhinged or any sides
making any traction you think on those
messages well I mean we're seeing the
polls narrow shortly it's now just plus
three for the Democrats and the latest
read of how this is going to go and you
know I think we've learned a lot about
polling in recent in recent years so I
think it's gonna be very interesting to
see how this whole thing shakes out but
in terms of those messages I can't help
but feel that they kind of scrambled to
them in the final weeks you know I think
that the Democrats were lacking a
cohesive message other than resistance
which clearly has been their main mojo
for the past couple of years and I think
Republicans have been having this you
know sort of schizophrenic reaction to
where they should be a lot of folks like
Paul Ryan feel that they should be very
focused on the economy the economy is
doing great it's a pretty easy argument
the president has gone more for the
jugular with immigration and the caravan
he's betting that that's going to help
some folks along the way and probably
he's betting that ultimately it's gonna
help him
won what do you think about the
Democrats bringing out the big guns
Barack Obama Joe Biden Mayor Bloomberg
dropping millions at the last week what
do you think about that well I think
that's good news for the Democrats
especially I think Bloomberg is a former
Republican I think people have a clear
sense something's wrong if you get
Bloomberg absolutely saying you know the
message that comes from this White House
is one of division hatefulness
finger-pointing as you saw in the ad
Jesse so what you see is that this picks
up on something that we're seeing right
now in the polls which is a plurality of
voters I think it's 40 percent say they
want to send a message with their vote
tomorrow to oppose Donald
41% saying they want their vote to put
more Democrats in position to be a check
on President Trump and I think also a
lot of people looking at the kind of
advertising that president Trump's
campaign has utilized the one about the
caravan is particular the one that had a
man who had been accused of killing
people as a centerpiece and somehow
representative of everyone in the
caravan you've seen Fox CNN and others
pull that ad off the ear as a racist and
so I think that this is interesting to
me because for the most part Democrats
have run on the issues especially health
care but what you're seeing now is that
more and more people are saying you know
what it's about who we are as you heard
President Obama former President Obama
say it's about who we are as Americans
who do we want to be our character yeah
I mean they're definitely bringing up
character and the late hours of the
campaign Dana and Juan said you know you
can really get a read on what people are
gonna think I'm not so sure I think we
have some sound of Nate silver famous
political prognosticator giving a very
very wide stretch of possibility about
what could happen Tuesday let's listen
to him
our range which covers 80% of outcomes
goes from on the low end about 15
Democratic pickups all the way up to the
low to mid-50s 52 or 53 most of those
are above 23 which is how many seats
they would need to take the house but
like but no one should be surprised if
they only win 19 seats and no one should
be surprised if the own if they win 51
seats those are both extremely possible
based on how accurate polls are in the
real world it's like the weatherman you
say you know tomorrow is gonna be 80 and
sunny but it's a possibility it could be
cold and rainy it's like I think it's
actually easier to predict the weather
and predict election outcomes even if
they're the extremes when he was talking
about like the Republicans hold the
house or the Democrats sweep it with
like 50 seats both of those there's a
chance there's smaller chances there's
probably gonna be something in between
I do think also that the gubernatorial
races are super important the
Republicans have dominated them in the
States for so long like maybe 12 years
and politics cycle and so it looks like
the Republicans are going to lose
several
those governorships and the ones are
really watch I think for if you're
thinking about president Trump's
re-election Florida and Ohio because
2020 you do the census you do
redistricting that will have a big
impact all right Greg one day to go you
look very excited I am thrilled thrilled
and cold I want to go back to what
Martha said I do feel like the Democrats
are cramming for a final there all
hopped up on ritalin and coffee because
they don't have a message this is what
the Democrats are faced with an economic
boom GDP wages jobs foreign policy the
almost thing that almost the destruction
of Isis it'll take some time
north progress with North Korea we're
seeing progress on trade we're seeing
Supreme Court two justices we're at
Keystone we forgotten about Keystone
we're rebuilding that we're rebuilding
the military there's consumer confidence
there's optimism there's worker
productivity any one of these singularly
as an achievement it's something you
could run on the problem with Trump is
he's got too many good things and so all
the Dems have is hate they're the party
of hate and they don't just hate Trump
they hate everybody who supports Trump
and that's what you have to remember
when you go to the polls that they're at
they actually despise you you know it's
kind of sad in a weird way it's a
tribute to Trump he's like a super
villain and he's bringing out Bloomberg
obama-biden celebrities they're like the
Super Friends they have to get together
to fight this one guy he's basically
he's basically I don't know like Lex
Luthor and they're all Robins yeah what
was that say to you about the Democratic
Party and it's in right now when they
have to bring in so many heavy hitters a
president who just left office just two
years ago coming and campaigning this
aggressively and this partisan Lee
against his successor it's not
necessarily unseemly but it's it's never
really happened to this extent before
does that mean that the Democrats are so
threatened that they have to come in
with the heavy artillery this late well
he has the bully pulpit he's the
president so he can do things like send
troops to the border for no reason he's
the one who can make an issue out of no
issue in terms of the caravanners oh
it's a threat it's an invasion your
children pull the children in the
I mean it's just madness and so I think
what you're seeing is a number of dem
top Democrats willing to step out in an
unorthodox fashion because they see this
as a critical moment I noticed in a lot
of ads both on the Republican and
Democratic side people are saying Jesse
this is the most important election in
our lifetime well you know they don't
have a message other than we hate Trump
now that is so get a bigger wave if they
don't get a blue wave they're gonna
blame the white Russian what is health
care isn't that an issue all right
well listen wanna we also have seen
Democrats rely on immigration Claire
McCaskill and the Indiana Donnelly guide
to